can we see this guy here the guy with
the horns yeah right there so here we
have here we have I guess the trans the
the non-binary uh demon Shaman this guy
ain't going to prison for three years
like that q and on Shaman with the
Buffalo horns he went to prison for what
was it three years that's not happened
to this guy even though Again by their
standards that's what this is this is an
Insurrection this is invading the
capital bill you have no right to be
there in staging this uh this protest
the other thing too that I you know I
appreciate I guess he's dressed up so
he's got this kind of like Priestly Garb
clown makeup devil horns what I
appreciate about it is that they make it
so easy to oppose them are we the
baddies okay they they always make it so
apparent and so clear who the bad guys
are they'll literally dress as demons in
case there's any confusion if you ever
become confused about it well the people
dressed as demons they're the bad guys